hi my name is Nicholas Wagner and I am
the
coach for the Barney and charter school
initiative we're going to be talking
about bar modeling which is one of the
three main Singaporean techniques for
modeling problems and for solving
problems those three that we emphasize
our number bonds place value and what
we're doing today
bar modeling I want to start off with a
more complex problem just to kind of
make an argument for the value of bar
modeling we're gonna solve this problem
using algebra and then I'm gonna solve
it a slightly different way using bar
models let's read the problem I have six
times as many muffins as scones and
twice as many muffins as Donuts
I have 170 pastries all together how
many doughnuts do I have so the first
step that you're going to do is you're
going to using algebra you're gonna set
up the variables muffins is equal to 6
times the number of scones my friends is
also equal to 2 times the number of
donuts and you know that muffins plus
scones plus Donuts is equal to 170 now
you got to get the the equation in terms
of one variable so we're gonna put the
equation in terms of donuts if if
muffins is equal to six guns then and
muffins is equal to two Donuts then we
know that six gowns is equal to two
Donuts by the transitive property of
equality
and therefore scones is the same thing
as two donuts divided by six by eight
division which can be reduced to donuts
divided by 3 so scones is equal to
one-third Donuts so then we can go back
and use substitution to put it back into
the equation where we have our total so
we have muffins which is equal to twice
the Donuts so let's go back here let's
go ahead and rewrite this my friends
plus Goins plus Donuts equal to 170 I'm
going to substitute muffins is the same
thing as 2 times the Donuts plus scones
is Donuts divided by 3 and then we
already have Donuts in terms of itself
it's equal to 170 so if you're familiar
with math you have to get a common
denominator to add those up so then I'm
gonna do that right here and I have that
six Donuts divided by three plus what we
already have Donuts divided by 3 which
was representing the scones plus three
doughnuts divided by 3 3 divided by 3
because that's 1 is equal to 170
pastries and then you see there that six
plus one plus three makes 10 donuts
divided by three it's equal to 170 you
multiply both sides by three to reduce
to one so you have ten Donuts it's equal
to 510
and then to solve for donuts alone
divided by 10 on both sides and you have
that donuts is equal to 51 so you have
51 donuts this problem and it is very
simple if you follow these steps in
algebra but there's an even simpler way
to approach this problem I'm gonna erase
the algebra and I'm gonna show you it
using a bar model and the way that I'm
going to do this is the way that I would
normally do this when I'm teaching is
that would read the problem all the way
through I would rewrite my question in
the form of a sentence so it says how
many donuts do I have I would rewrite it
as I have blank donuts by the way the
process that I'm explaining to you right
now I would do frequently with every
problem that I have so that students
know kind of process how to a
step-by-step structure that they can
follow because some students need to
know where to start they need a place to
start so we look a the problem all the
way through then we say restate the
question and the form of a sentence and
then we go back and chunk it and read
through it a piece at a time and stop
when I can draw something I have six
times as many muffins as scones so I
know I have muffins and I have scones
and if my scones is one unit my muffins
is going to be six units
sorry I'm a bit of a perfectionist
probably still won't come out perfectly
but so six times the number of muffins
as scones okay I could draw that and
continue and twice as many muffins as
donuts so I have Donuts and my muffins
are twice as many as my Donuts which
means I'm going to have how many of
these units I'm gonna have three of them
if don't it muffins is twice as many
than Donuts is half as many don't have
the muffins so I will have three of
these units notice these are all three
equal sized units or bars and so what I
can do with them is like Oh before I
continue I'm going to throw in my total
I have not finished reading the problem
so I continue until I finished reading
the problem I have 170 pastries
altogether and now I come to my question
how many donuts do I have so I'm going
to put a line here
with a question mark looking for that
final answer so I'm gonna total up the
number of units that I have which I
count as ten of these bars and ten of
those bars which are representing the
pastries is equal to 170 and total so
then we should get it down to one bar so
we know how much one of these units is
worth so I divide both sides by 10 so
that one bar is equal to 17 but I'm not
quite finished how many of these units
am I looking for looking for three of
them because that's the donuts so I
multiply by three
on both sides and I have three of these
bars is equal to 51 and I've solved my
problem for many people this is a much
more intuitive process is much clearer
to students and I think that it is a
very helpful technique so before we
continue and do more problems I'd like
to explain the basic setup of types of
bar models there are two types of bar
models in terms of their basic form and
that is the part hole model and the
comparison model
so we have part-whole which some people
call the part part whole model and then
we have the comparison model okay the
part whole model looks very similar to
what we've seen in terms of a number
bond before we have our whole quantity
and then we have a part here and a part
here okay so you can use this largely
for problems relating to addition and
subtraction you can have the whole and
apart and you're looking for another
part you're gonna have both parts
looking for the whole and you can
continue to make all the different
iterations of that then we have our
comparison a comparison model which is a
larger quantity and a smaller quantity
sometimes there will be multiple
quantities here but I'm giving you the
simplest form then you have the
difference between them and your total
bracket
okay so those are the two types of
models I recommend for the remainder of
the video that you take a second to
write those down in your notes and
reference them as we continue to do some
of these problems so here's the part
hole and a comparison
okay before we start practicing though I
want to make a few notes students may
draw different models for the same
problem so the same idea applies that
you need to allow for creativity in the
problem-solving that you're doing in
your math class if a student draws a
different bar model take a minute if you
have a document camera to take that
picture and put it under the document
camera and show you a class and walk
through what was different about their
model is their model accurate does it
still work even though it looks
different so there's no one right
approach to solving a particular problem
necessarily you can also ask students
what do you like about that model versus
the other model and get them to compare
and use explanation use language to to
really figure out how to articulate what
it is that they like about models and
what they like about another model so
let's go ahead and try a problem Stacy
had 2378 books
she sold 259 of them
at a yard sale how many did she have
left this would be you can do it both
ways actually with a part hole or a
comparison and one thing that you'll
recognize is that students will come up
with the different models on their own
and they'll start to realize that
there's certain words maybe that would
recommend that would suggest that they
should use a comparison model over a
part hole model or they might get to the
end of drawing one model not like it
scratch it out and switch to the other
model that's okay
allow them to really find their
preference and they'll start to
recognize that it is true that there are
certain problems that just lend
themselves more naturally to one or the
other so this one I'm going to use a
part hole model on so I have my total or
I guess I should back up for a second
and reiterate what I just did moments
ago you read through the whole problem
Stacie you had two thousand three
hundred seventy eight books she sold two
hundred fifty nine of them at a yard
sale
how many did she have left after we do
that
remember we come down to our sentence we
write our sentence I want to reiterate
that this process following this process
really gives structure to some students
and approaching word problems so my
sentence is down here and how many eight
did she have left you would write Stacie
had blank books left
so we know that she going backed we
would start our model again Stacey had
2378 books I can draw that these are the
number of books that she has and they
the total is two thousand three hundred
seventy eight now we keep reading
she sold two hundred fifty nine of them
all right sold the quantity would be two
hundred fifty nine and you want to know
how many did she have left one important
note I recommend only putting your
question mark where the final answer is
going to be you might have a multi-step
problem if you have a multi-step problem
you can throw other question marks in
there but if you do that I recommend
putting the question mark and an F for
final or some note that that's what I'm
actually finally trying to end on okay
I'm going to go ahead and skip the
arithmetic for the sake of the length of
the video but I wanted to show you that
this is how you would model this problem
and you would do you have the whole you
have a part and you're looking for the
other part so this would be a
subtraction problem okay
the next problem that we're going to do
it is going to be a comparison jerry has
six dollars more than Kevin Kevin has 11
dollars how much money do they have
altogether
all right so I've already read the
problem once through with you I would go
next to my sentence how much money do
they have all together
Jerry and Kevin have blank dollars all
together so then we're going to go back
and break the problem into parts that I
can draw Jerry has six dollars more than
Kevin so I have Jerry's amount and
Kevin's dollars so Jerry's dollars and
Kevin's dollars some people will just
start start drawing the problem some
people like to give them equal
quantities first and then extend the one
that has more Jerry has six dollars more
than Kevin extend that the difference
here is that six dollars right and Kevin
has eleven dollars how much do they have
altogether and that's where I'm going to
put my question mark because I'm looking
for the total so I know that this is six
dollars this is going to be eleven
dollars and what's helpful about drawing
them as equal bars is you get to see
that those are the same and that the
difference here is six dollars so you
now know that Jerry has 17 dollars
and Kevin has $11 so 17 plus 11 is $28
okay so this is a comparison you have a
larger quantity a smaller quantity a
difference and a total come back down
here and complete your sentence another
thing I should mention that and I'll
give credit where credit's to Kevin
Mahoney who has who has has been doing
Singapore Math for many years dr. Kevin
Mahoney has this has created this
structure where you have the the
question you have the answer sentence
and then you have kind of a a break
between the bar model and the arithmetic
so students really who struggle with
knowing where to put things
and who might get stuck solving problem
know what the format should look like
it's very helpful for those students as
they continue to grow in their comfort
with where to place things you no longer
have to format it for them they should
just know how to start doing it on their
own
let's go ahead and do a few few
different problems from these like to
show you a variety just so you have
familiarity with these I'm stealing
these from the dimensions math three a
teacher's guide on page 126 which is
chapter 4 multiplication and division
just so you have the notes on where to
go to but I wanted to walk through them
with you there are three children each
child has eight pencils
okay how many pencils do they have and
all I'm going to go ahead and skip the
normal walkthrough of the formatting and
just go ahead and draw the model for you
there are three children each child has
8 pencils I want to note something here
some students may want to write an 8
underneath each of these that is okay
that is less abstract so they may
eventually move to where it's more
abstract and they understand that these
are all equal quantities and you're
wanting to know how many pencils they
have all together so this is
representing pencils so that's how I
would set that problem up there there
would be 8 times 3 which is 24 pencils
so they would all have 24 pencils I mean
they would have all 24 pencils in all it
changes to a slight variation of the
same problem mrs. Turner has 24 pencils
she gives each of her three students an
equal number of pencils forgive my
shorthand how many pencils does each
student receive
okay so we know mrs. Turner has a
quantity of 24 pencils these are pencils
yeah I know your total 24 she gives them
to three students which means we're
going to break this bar into three equal
quantities and you're wanting to know
how many pencils does each student have
so you are looking for this quantity
there so you would do 24 divided by
three gives you this one which is eight
all right so that's it's a different
type of multiplication problem
now I want to give you one of the
division types of problems
mrs. Turner has 24 pencils
she gives three pencils to each of our
students and you are looking for how
many students receive pencils all right
so you start with this quantity again of
twenty four pencils each student is
receiving three and you want to know how
many threes fit into 24 so there are a
variety of ways to do this one the way
that the dimensions text has it is that
there's a three here at the beginning a
three here at the end to show that you
don't know how many is going to be in
between or how many there are altogether
in terms of students so this is a
student another way that I've seen this
drawn is to do a similar model and this
is actually the model that I prefer so
this is a different picture option two
let's call this option one so you can
clearly do any 82 and use an ellipse
here to show that this is gonna be
continued and you don't know for how
long this is the model that I prefer
however both are great and both are
useful I should introduce you to a third
way of doing this that I've seen in
textbooks and I believe is still used in
the dimensions 6a book which is where
they leave a space here showing that you
have three you know you have 24 on top
and you do not know how many of these
are gonna go in there because it's a
broken a broken bar I think this has
been in my experience less intuitive to
students than this or this so I would
prefer one of these two models if you're
teaching six 6a dimensions you'll see
this but you might show your students
this as well okay I think that's all
that I have for you actually before we
before we go there are a few things that
I'd like to highlight why I bought bar
modeling is useful so let me let me
discuss that for a second first of all
it's it's going to give you a model of
the problem and I think it's worth
noting that you could take any of my bar
models and once I have completed my bar
model I no longer need the words so so
the model can be used by itself
another point it's erasable which is
really nice you can you can change it as
you need to a third point you can you
can make adjustments and use the bar
model for all it's worth so quickly you
can quickly adjust the problem for
example on the last problem that we had
up here instead of 24 and 3 you can
change the numbers to 2 different
numbers you can say what if I change the
24 how does that change the problem so
you can quickly adjust the problem I
think it's worth mentioning that you
have insight into how a student is
reading the problem or understanding
what the problem is saying a lot of
times students don't make the mistakes
so much on the math itself but on the
reading portion so I think it's it's
worth noting that sometimes there might
be a reading difficulty as opposed to a
math ability issue I like to say here
that one of the big things or one of the
things that I like to say to teachers
when I'm training is a picture is worth
and then I let them fill it in a
thousand words so if you have a picture
do you have a bar model you really do
have some keen understanding of how
they're interpreting the problem so so
once you have this then you know you
have insight into errors
okay so these are all points that I
really like to highlight on why we use
bar bonding so that's all I have for you
thank you very much